[Music]
that Cardassians are back at it like
obsessed with sushi they're always
getting to see their dog is named sushi
she's making sushi I don't know anything
about the Kardashians I love them super
fan huge fan obsessed Kylie Jenner is
pregnant right I didn't even know Kim
Kardashian had kids I don't think she's
good this is not the first time I've
questioned a Kardashian method and I'm
pretty sure it's not gonna be the last
this is not some crazy new weird hot dog
suit it's kind of like spam musubi from
Hawaii like a Korean sausage kimbap just
things that we've always had I love hot
dogs I don't care if they're in sushi
I'm gonna eat the hot dogs if cam took
the time out of her day to make these
hot dog rolls
I'll chop it I'll basically do anything
there so I'm ready for the hot dogs I'm
ready for the sushi I'm ready for the
Kardashians bring it on looks just like
I thought it would I see you Kim this
really isn't so bad I don't know whether
I should ask for mustard or soy sauce to
be fair if they sold this at an Asian
supermarket and like did a package take
a little bamboo leaf $3 totally buy it
[Music]
that's great I honestly like it cuz it
is literally just went rice and a hot
dog in seaweed I love it actually love
it this is a kind of thing yeah my mom
would make me if she loved me I like
your optimism and how open your
tastebuds I'm really feeling it bro it's
just not my thing
it's not my thing I think what makes Kim
Kardashian so accessible and the
Kardashian family so accessible is that
they're relatable and aspirational at
the same time it's weird that Kim
Kardashian kind of momentarily shines a
light on something that we don't know
about and everyone's like flocking to
this thing that seems weird it's really
nothing new and it's a great thing to
have it's not that weird it's not weird
in college I would eat like cheddar
cheese and salsa in a wrap will welcome
her graciously into her family mostly
because of her immense well that also
your hot dog sushi great fantastic bring
it to the family
party everybody loved it